when do you feel like you kind of like
figured out how to like properly
turn the rap [__] into a business and
like really monetize your fan base
uh I started I started looking in the
analytics everything like where where
certain fans to listen to music from uh
like top cities like what type of like
I'm really looking at what type of songs
they're streaming the most you feel me
like
like certain rap songs just do good on
YouTube but then like like a song that's
for the females like singing melodizing
that's that's doing hella good on like
like Spotify or something and I'm
looking at and it's like cities that I
never expected so like where
like right now my Spotify list last time
I looked at it I think
the top five I think it was like
Melbourne Australia London uh there was
like three out of country cities oh [__]
yeah and it'd be like it'd be like for
songs like like the the the singing
songs you feel me that's so crazy to
think like Australia's really far Halo
foreign
so when you see some [__] like that or
you're like damn maybe we should try to
go do some shows out there or
run some ads out there try to you know
like like how do you take that
information and like how do you apply it
to like what you're doing
uh yeah we try to we try to do like try
to try to have ads reach towards towards
that way
um
we we were actually speaking to somebody
from out there like a promoter trying to
get some shows together
but uh that's on hold right now trying
to put that together uh try to have a
show with Canada and then and they
didn't even let me in which was weird
because they let me in in uh Toronto and
uh Montreal is it because of your record
yeah but but it did me so greasy this
time like they looked at everything like
they even uh broken even getting they
was bringing up stuff from like when he
was 14. really this is crazy was this
Vancouver yeah Vancouver damn so like
you how does it work you get to the
border so yeah we get over there we go
through the little uh I forgot what it's
called uh what's it called when you go
we go to TJ Customs Customs yeah so we
win customs
um
they see me whatever I guess I guess I
kind of throw them off with the face
tattoos and [__] uh they they looked me
up I guess they seen I was a rapper then
they look up everything else that's on
the internet the indict the the little
indictment [__] and just the [__] that
was on like blogs and all that [__] so
all that pop up
day on everything I on my on my two
suitcases I got two bandanas on it just
to identify it right and so you know
what when you yeah yeah you know what
I'm saying it but but it happened to be
blue so they asking why is why is it
blue I'm like that's the that's the
first thing I see I just put it on there
yeah but
they have they bring me to like a little
room in the back
they're like we gotta ask you a couple
questions
I'm like all right whatever [__] it
bro they have me in there for like eight
hours eight hours bro just add like like
damn you're interrogating me just to
deny you oh my whole lot like asking me
about my whole life like everything like
go back to the waiting room
all right there's a couple more
questions we gotta ask go back in here
for like two hours I go back to the
waiting room
it had me doing that back and forth and
then and then the day was coming to an
end there was nobody else coming in
there was like
um
uh based on the information you gave us
we still got to do some more research
like more stuff come up
so I'm like damn they're like uh it
might be a it might be a a a legal issue
now
because you're they're trying to sell as
an active [__] and you feel me just a
little [__] like that now now it's a
legal issue and I'm like a legal issue
like like what are you talking about I
instantly called I actually called Matt
who's a lawyer and yeah the lawyer and
my real lawyer right uh uh mark
so I called him they get in contact with
them trying to see what's up uh uh Mark
and Matt get a hold of it uh the uh was
it the embassy or something like that
trying to talk to them uh they're like
you're gonna have to spend the night in
uh in custody so we could do more
homework on you what the [__] yeah if
you try to get into a country yeah I was
like [__] that I gotta go they're like
you can't leave there's no there's
unless you can find a flood there's like
we'll give you an exception if you could
find a flight to the US right now we'll
let you leave but they were like there
isn't any though so you're gonna have to
spend the night and it could possibly
become a legal issue because you're
organized uh what they say a gang member
that's coming into the country or some
[__] like that
so I'm looking I'm like give me five
minutes bro I find a flight right now so
we looking there I'm on the three-way
with Matt and the lawyer and we're just
trying to find a flight to get up out of
there the first flight I seen it was in
New York so I just bought a ticket to
New York got up out of there what the
[__] bro I was there so long yeah
so you were trying to drive like you
drove to the Border or did you fly there
we flew so you fly into Vancouver to the
airport and before they let you into the
country they pretty much hit you with
the line of course yeah so
so when I first went to Toronto uh the
dude kind of gave me a little bit of
issue I got in contact with my lawyer
Thunder but uh but the dude was cool so
what they were saying they really depend
on who's working at the time right but I
guess Vancouver more uh streak because
uh it's connected to California you feel
me right damn that's crazy so you just
flew to New York yeah flew to New York
spent the night over there and had to
fly back that [__] is well I was on a
plane for like a whole day that sounds
like a terrible 24 it's terrible 32
hours
terrible